certainly true that games are sort of a
superset of all other media you can put
a book in a game you can put a movie in
a game you can you can put play in a
game you can put anything into a game
but these but you can't necessarily put
games into all these other media because
when you when you look when you take a
step out and like what's going on with
digital gaming ultimately any kind of
media can go in there and as we kind of
push into the 21st century we're going
to see this happening we're going to see
every kind of media getting subsumed
into video games and that I would have
to think that by the end of the 21st
century the video games will be the
defining medium of the 21st century
I think there's the primary
technological barrier that keeps us from
being more emotionally engaged with
video games is the barrier of speech
computers can can can talk they have
sound they can take touch inputs they
have cameras but one of the things they
they really can't do is listen to us and
as Professor Chris Swain at USC and he
speaks about this very very eloquently
he points out that at the beginning of
the 20th century we had silent film and
nobody took it very seriously as a
medium it was kind of a toy it was kind
of an amusement a minor thing until it
learned to talk and once film could
speak suddenly it started to sort of
take over the world and by the end of
the 20th century it was the dominant
medium and as he likes to put it a film
of became the literature of the 20th
century and he then suggests that games
are in the same place that silent films
were except that now it's not about them
talking it's about them listening and
once you can have a meaningful
conversation with an artificially
created video game character with just
your voice the potential for this to be
an emotional medium rapidly grows and
just expands and it will suddenly become
incredibly more natural and and this
business of there's two parts where
right part of it is having computers
understand speech understand what we say
just understand the very words but then
to understand it in context and to be
able to form appropriate responses as
these two things start to grow and come
together we're going to see a medium
like we've never seen before
when you look at the difference between
literature film and video games and the
types of stories that we have what we
see in literature are stories that are
very much about personal drama and
emotion and conflict and when you see
video games everything's about action
everything's below the neck all the
verbs that are happening or jumping and
running and moving and everything is
about the physical and everything in
literature is about the emotional and
film is somewhere in the middle because
we can't necessarily hear what's going
on inside people's heads in film and we
can see them so we have this interesting
mix in film what will happen is suddenly
video games will be able to go over to
the literature side but in but in a much
more powerful way because you'll be able
to have gaming experiences that are all
about interacting with characters in a
very emotional intense way to be able to
have conversations with characters games
where where you'll you'll the verbs will
change from running and shooting and
jumping and ducking to persuading and uh
you know and and antagonizing and you
know and convincing and compelling and
begging and pleading it'll be it'll be a
very different kind of kind of game
because it as well as being able to
sense just the words that you've said
and what you mean it will be possible to
sense you know the emotion it's already
we can easily sense a facial expression
on some level and as technology improves
will be able to sense that more and more
and be also be able to sense other
emotions and you won't be able that
there will be games where the only way
you're able to win is by engaging in a
meaningfully emotional way with a
virtual character and that has to be an
incredibly powerful experience